let's get that wig on look how beautiful
that effin like Julia Child let me get a
beautiful green alright y'all so on our
show I had to show you his chair NAS
when actually and we made slime together
it was edible slime it was amazing but
today I have a new challenge before me I
have to make fluffy beautiful slime with
no instructions which I've never done
that
that's like things my husband does he
doesn't read instructions I always read
the instructions so I have to make it
and there's no do-overs
so this version is not edible I will not
be eating it but I'm gonna start off
apparently this is I need a vat of
Elmer's glue for this and this is
contact solution for this baking soda
shaving cream and then we have different
colors for my slime and then we have
water and then mixing but who needs
these I don't even know how much to mix
so why am I gonna use those little
pinchy roll do you and I think I'm gonna
start with a little Elmer's glue that's
what I'm gonna do oh my gosh that's
heavy where does one get this much
Elmer's glue there we go let's make it
like okay what wait what okay
whoa right back in alright now I'm gonna
do this with both of them this is hard
what's wrong with this side you're so
sad okay you suck so here we go I'm
getting stuff everywhere okay we're
gonna do that that is how much you need
for slime because I said so contact
solution let's get it wet okay and then
let's do some baking soda get some fluff
when the making dough okay we're just
gonna put some water sure let's get them
out and let's do a little green that's
my sons they love both sons actually
love green and then you yeah you just
mix it that's how you make this this is
how you make that look how beautiful
that Emily Julia Child get a beautiful
green color I don't know if this is this
isn't gonna be any glue I need something
else this isn't this is like just like
shaving cream it looks like wait what
maybe that's why I have the vat of glue
cuz that's what makes it stick okay more
glue step consistency it's congealing
quite nicely okay and let's see if the I
mean that looks that looks slimy I think
it looks pretty slimy I think I did
pretty good that's pretty good right I
mean are you lying to me are you yes
person right now I feel like it's pretty
good look at that look at that
consistency so basically I nailed no
instructions needed for making slime
that's what I just nailed you can try at
home but I don't know I'm kind of
skilled
oh good luck I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this